madame monsieur bonsoir
l'accident est survenu en début d'après
midi à l'occasion d'un vol de
démonstration au dessus de l'aéroport de
mulhouse dans le haut rhin
un avion airbus de la nouvelle série des
a320 s'est écrasé au sol alors qu'il
venait de survoler la piste à basse
altitude
l'appareil a semble-t-il accroché le
fait d'un arbre pour l'instant le
dernier bilan fait état de quatre morts
98 blessés sur les 127 personnes
équipage compris qu'ils se trouvaient à
bord tous invités un baptême de l'air
sur cet avion
d'autres victimes pourraient encore être
coincé à l'intérieur de la carlingue
voici les premières images filmées tout
de suite après l'accident
gérard beaufils l'airbus volait à très
faible vitesse à basse altitude train
d'atterrissage sortie le pilote n'a pas
repris assez de puissance pour remonter
la queue de l'appareil a heurté la cime
des arbres
l'avion s'est écrasé à 800 mètres des
pistes de l'aérodrome d'habsheim en
pleine forêt coupant la végétation sur
150 mètres de long et 50 de large
une rescapée a confirmé avoir bien
entendu le frottement sous la carlingue
avant que l'airbus n'aura que le sol et
s'immobilise brutalement évacué par
l'équipage au moyen de toboggan quelques
passagers ne souffre miraculeusement que
de contusions
d'importants moyens de secours dépêchés
sur place ont permis d'extraire
également d'autres passagers plus
gravement atteints notamment ceux qui se
trouvaient à l'avant de l'appareil qui a
pris feu après l'impact au sol ce soir
une chapelle ardente vient d'être dressé
près de l'aérodrome d'habsheim le bilan
encore provisoire de quatre morts et 98
blessés pourrait en effet s'alourdir
dans les heures qui viennent
voilà donc pour les premières images et
les faits